hi I'm Erik Bosse and Deadpool 2 is here
following up its first movie with even
more irreverent self-parody of the
superhero genre including even the way
it handles it's hilarious post-credits
scene spoilers head if you haven't seen
deadpool 2 yet i'm gonna talk about the
movies ending and big twists you know
things that might come up in a video
about a movie sports credits scenes okay
there are two post credits scenes after
deadpool - one mid-credits scene and the
second longer post credit montage the
first scene clarifies the movies ending
with a new turn of events
so of course Deadpool 2 ends with
Deadpool sacrificing himself to save
Russell aka fire fist Cable has come
back in time on a mission to assassinate
Russell an unstable mutant who would
grow up to wreak havoc and kill cable's
wife and kid in the future we'd
recovering from the death of Vanessa
early in the film swears to protect the
kid at all costs so after briefly
teaming up with cable to rein in the
kids destructive streak
Deadpool saves Russell by jumping in
front of cables bullet Deadpool had put
on one of those mutant ability
inhibiting collars stopping his
regenerative powers and keeping the
bullet lodged in him killing him this
allows Russell to learn human kindness
preventing his horrible future in saving
cables family while allowing Wade to
reunite with Vanessa in heaven triple
win roll credits but wait that brings us
to the first post credits scene the
mid-credits scene we see cable with his
time-travel device but instead of using
it to return to the future to be with
his now not dead wife and kid he instead
depletes its energy to go back in time a
little to save Deadpool he does this by
slipping a lead coin in Deadpool suit to
block the bullet remember this coin was
important Wade it was from he and
Vanessa's first state and cable had
stolen it from him earlier on now he
returns it with the added bonus of
saving Wade's life and the added bonus
of leaving cables stranded in the
present timeline to start and lead the
x-force another triple win roll credits
but wait this brings us to the final
post credit montage at the very end of
the credits we find negasonic teenage
warhead with ukyo and the x-mansion
tinkering with cables time-travel device
negasonic says when something so small
generates enough energy to reverse time
and Deadpool just cuts are all saying
whoa just fix it 11 or I'll take it to
the Genius Bar to see [ __ ] Sonic's
moody attitude and short hair by
comparing her to the little girl from
stranger things they tossed the fix
device to Deadpool and Yukio says cables
gonna kill you when he finds out
Deadpool respond
never heard of him and they get sonic
says yeah what do you think I'm helping
him then Deadpool leans out of the room
saying the Lord works in mysterious ways
don't I have a good day leaving
megasonic AM Yukio to realize what a
mistake they probably made then the fun
starts
Deadpool goes back in time to prevent
Vanessa's death killing the last
attacker in that scene with kitchenware
then Deadpool saves Peter as well Peter
along with bedlam Zeitgeist chatter
starring the others also died in the
events of the movie but Deadpool stops
Peter and tells him to not try to help
site-geist convincing him to return to
his normal life and by the way this is
all set to Cher's if I could turn back
time which is like the perfect choice
for all this but next things get meta
because Deadpool and we find ourselves
in the scene from the movie x-men
origins Wolverine it's the famously
cringy moment in which Ryan Reynolds
older version of Deadpool was revealed
with the tattoos in the mouth and
explicably sewn shut they reused the
actual footage from x-men origins with
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine sane Stryker
finally found a way to shut you up but
they reshot the angle with Wolverines
claws in the foreground and old Deadpool
at a distance but with the new Deadpool
stepping into frame to shoot him in the
head they cut to a reverse shot to make
it look like Hugh Jackman is reacting
confused but then they come back to
Deadpool who says just cleaning up the
timelines as he plugs old Deadpool over
and over and over again so Deadpool was
referencing the way x-men Days of Future
past use time travel to retcon and fix
the confusing timelines of the x-men
films changing events in the mid 70s so
that the events of x-men origins which
most people agree is a pretty bad film
could be replaced with a new timeline of
events Ryan Reynolds has been a longtime
fan of the Deadpool comics and he was
one of the people leading the charge to
get a true Deadpool movie made it was a
huge struggle for the past decade and a
half until 2016 when it eventually
happened Reynolds was offered to play a
version of Wade Wilson and x-men origins
in 2009 and even though the movies take
on the character was pretty off Reynolds
did take the role after being convinced
to introduce the character to the world
but yeah his 2016 version has been in a
lot of ways redemption for that Deadpool
and this post-credit time-travel scene
is him taking another step to make
things right a similar meta apology
comes up in the final part of this
montage featuring Ryan Reynolds playing
a younger version of himself reading the
script for the movie Green Lantern he
says to himself you're in the big
leagues now kid but then blam his blood
sprays on the script and he slumps over
to reveal Deadpool who says to camera
you're welcome Canada this is another
exam
Reynolds soup by the way is Canadian
making fun of his own movie superhero
career specifically the Green Lantern
movie in 2011 which most fans did not
enjoy including Reynolds himself who
recently revealed that he never watched
the completed film he also joked about
this process in the first Deadpool movie
and please don't make the supersuit
green or animated before we go too far
down this rabbit hole of trying to
explain how this sequence could change
the x-men Deadpool timeline coolers Jets
we should clearly look at these scenes
as meta jokes
obviously if Ryan Reynolds killed
himself there would be no 2016 Deadpool
or 2018 Deadpool - either this
time-travel stuff is confusing that's
the point there was even a rumored
additional part of this post credit
montage that would feature Deadpool
going further back in time to kill
Hitler as a baby a reference to the
time-travel thought experiment that this
whole movie's plot with cable and Russel
is inspired by but the baby Hitler scene
was deleted after test screenings
however I think we can interpret the
stuff we saw cable and Deadpool do to
change the timelines of these post
credits scenes as real Deadpool is still
alive so is Vanessa and so is Peter I'm
just saying this in case we ever get a
third Deadpool movie or an x-force movie
this would leave the door open for these
characters to return and for any of
those dum-dums who left the moment the
credits started rolling
tough luck you're gonna be confused that
said there's no guarantee that any
future Deadpool movie could even happen
Disney is still in negotiations with box
to acquire the rights to its film
properties including Deadpool in the
x-men meaning this could be the last
time we see this version of Deadpool in
a movie so going wild with time travel
in these final moments could just be
this movie going for broke as if there's
no tomorrow
because sadly when it comes to Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool there really might not
be but I'm curious to know from you guys
since Deadpool to essentially presented
two endings one with Wade in heaven with
Vanessa and one in which he and Vanessa
get brought back through time travel
which ending do you prefer now to be
sure the post-credit ending is hilarious
and it leaves the door open for sequels
which I love but from a cinematic
standpoint I was honestly okay with how
things ended before the credits roll
comment with your thoughts down below
and you can tweet me directly at a box
or follow new rock stars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like and share
this video subscribe to new rock stars
for all kinds of deep dives in a
Deadpool including a full movie
breakdown with all the subtle references
and easter eggs that you might have
missed that'll be coming up very soon
thanks for watching bye